hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is the final retail hardware of the
oneplus 2 now I did do a previous video
on the oneplus 2 my first impressions
video which if you haven't already seen
will be right there
that was a pre-release hardware so this
is exactly what people who buy the phone
are going to be getting in the mail when
they get their package so I'm going to
do an unboxing video I haven't done one
of those in a while but also I'll go a
little bit further than that I'm going
to set this phone up as my daily driver
I'm going to put my sim card in this
thing so you know it's legit
so my first apps put my homescreen
together and basically make it my daily
phone so you get a little bit of insight
on what I do when I get a new phone and
I want to do that so that me further ado
let's get into it
so the oneplus 2 unboxing experience is
obviously super simple right you just
get the phone itself and then some
paperwork and then the charging adapter
and the USB type-c cable which is
actually really nice it's this
rubberized material and a flat
anti-tangle shaped cord so everyone plus
two comes with the sandstone black back
which is very similar to last year's I'd
say maybe a little bit more hard or more
coarse but the back is also removable to
drop in any other materials on the back
via a style swap cover but first thing
I'll do before setting up is drop my sim
card in mine so I have a nano SIM and
oneplus 2 actually has support for two
nano SIM cards two sim card slots and I
dropped my sim card in slot number one
and we are good to go
if this was a phone with a micro SD card
slot I would also at this point install
that too but I basically only use those
for music then I went through all of the
setup process for signing in to my
Google account and then going all
through the more specific oxygen OS
specific oneplus two setups which
include choosing between software and
hardware buttons I'm going to take
advantage of the whole display and use
the hardware buttons and then also
enabling any screen off our gestures
which you may find useful both of these
things can also of course at any time be
enabled or changed later in the settings
also I chose the Google keyboard here
although
that didn't seem to work and then I
enabled shelf which is the leftmost
homescreen on the oxygen OS launcher
which I kind of like and then boom we
are in also the oneplus two comes with
this pre-installed screen protector on
it but since I'm going on rogue here I'm
going to take it off okay so at this
point once I've signed into my Google
account usually it takes a minute or two
while everything gets situated and
starts sinking because I have a lot of
stuff in Google you know calendars
contacts etc the phone has to pull all
the stuff down then of course you got to
make sure that I'm on the latest version
of the OS so this one actually did
require a quick update and then make
sure you have the latest version of all
the pre-installed apps veteran Google
Play thankfully there's pretty much no
bloatware with these new stock Android
phones that's part of what I like so
much about them but yeah I updated
everything here and then it's just a
matter of installing a few of my
must-have apps for me the first app I
install on I want to say pretty much
every phone I get no joke is Dropbox I
keep a lot of stuff in Dropbox including
photo samples when I'm testing a camera
and then I also like to grab wallpapers
from my Dropbox and set it on the phone
and I also side loaded the newest
hangouts 4.0 app onto this phone which
was a good opportunity to enable unknown
sources and allow it to install any apk
I want for future sideloading
I also went in and switched over to the
Google keyboard my favorite since it
knows my typing pretty well already and
for some reason it was still using Swift
key even though I chose Google keyboard
before so I set that again and then I
grabbed a couple of my other most used
apps like Phoenix for Twitter is one
which I get a lot of questions about yes
I think it's one of the best Twitter
apps for Android and I do think it's
worth like two bucks or whatever it
costs I also grab pocket which is useful
app for me when saving stuff I want to
remember later and this will also be a
good time to have it stop automatically
adding icons for new apps to the
homescreen
that's always been bugging me when I
first set up a phone so I'd uncheck that
another app I use a lot Spotify I have a
bunch of playlists there and I listen to
music all the time especially when
traveling so I always grab Spotify
another one I've been using more
recently is SoundCloud where you'll find
I guess less popular music but still
some really great stuff it lets me sign
in with my Google account so it's really
easy and yeah I'll try to link my
soundcloud playlists or likes below if I
can also Google Calendar
is like my life so I pretty much always
have a Google Calendar widget of some
kind on any of my home screens the
prettiest one right now is called today
calendar widget it works best with some
wallpapers better than others but it's
basically a semi-transparent or even
completely transparent if you want it to
be a list of all your upcoming
appointments which is super helpful for
me in this agenda form then of course I
like to go through the device settings
itself like setting up a fingerprint if
the device has a fingerprint reader and
also specifically for the oneplus 2 for
me setting up the home button actions to
take advantage of the fact that it has a
physical home button so I use a double
tap to trigger the camera which is
really quick by the way so that I don't
have to have a camera icon anywhere on
the home screens anymore and using a
long press to get into Google now and
then of course since I'm triggering
Google now for the first time setting
that up real quick
I do use Google now a lot especially to
trigger navigation so Google now is
always nice to have last but not least
here's a little pro tip to help the
device even when it's brand new or not
feel even faster than it already is go
into the device settings and about phone
and scroll down to the build number and
then tap on that build number a bunch of
times until it eventually says you are
now a developer then go back into the
settings and you should see a new option
in the settings called developer options
and in here is always a whole bunch of
rightfully hidden more complex stuff
that most people will never mess with
but the one I always seem to go back to
play with is animation speed and in
custom roms like oxygen OS here you can
choose slightly faster animation speeds
throughout the OS so like 0.75 X makes
all the animations on the phone
take point seven five times the time and
speeds it up a little bit you could even
choose point five or even faster if you
want but overall this makes the phone
feel a lot quicker a lot snappier so
there you have it that's my unboxing and
setting up of the oneplus 2 let me know
if you guys want to see especially in
the full review basically as I test this
phone over the next week or two
hopefully we can put together a list to
make this the most thorough
comprehensive review possible thanks for
watching this one and I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace
you